I CAN SAY I'M CERTAINLY ROOTING
FOR YOU TONIGHT.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: IT PROBABLY WON'T
HELP.
SOME CANDIDATES ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE FLIPPING THE
BIRD TO THE NRA WHILE OTHERS
BACK FROM STYLE IMMIGRATIONS,
IT'S NOT QUITE CLEAR WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC MESSAGES FOR 2018.
BRIT HUME IS FOX'S SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST.
HE WATCHES CAREFULLY.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
WHAT YOU THINK THE MESSAGES, OR
IS THERE A NATIONAL MESSAGE THAT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SELLING
THIS MIDTERM?
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY
INDISTINCT AT THIS MOMENT IF
THERE IS ONE.
I THINK MUCH OF THE PARTY IS SO
MESMERIZED BY DONALD TRUMP AND
LOADS HIM SO DEEPLY THAT THAT
HAS BECOME KIND OF THE CENTRAL
THING AND THE CENTRAL THEME THAT
YOU CAN SEE.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
APPEARS TO BE MOSTLY ABOUT RIGHT
NOW.
I SUSPECT AS TIME GOES ON
SOMETHING MORE ORIENTED TOWARDS
BORDERS WILL COME ALONG.
BUT REMEMBER, TUCKER.
THESE CANDIDATES ARE RUNNING IN
A PARTY WHERE 71%, ACCORDING TO
ONE RECENT POLL, WANT
DONALD TRUMP IMPEACHED.
SO IT'S KIND OF UNDERSTANDABLE
THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME FOCUS
ON HIM.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
MOST DEMOCRATS ARE, OF COURSE,
VERY ANTI-DRUM, THAT'S WHY THEY
ARE DEMOCRATS.
BUT IS THAT A MESSAGE THAT MOVES
PEOPLE TO THE POLLS?
>> BASED ON THE EVIDENCE WE
HAVE, IT SEEMS NOT TO BE WORKING
VERY WELL, AND THE REASON I SAY
THAT IS, LOOK AT THE ADVANTAGES
THAT DEMOCRATS ENJOY GOING INTO
THIS MIDTERM ELECTION.
FIRST OF ALL, THE POLITICAL
GRAVITY AND ANY PRESIDENT'S
FIRST MIDTERM IS ALWAYS WITH THE
OTHER PARTY AND THE AVERAGE LOSS
IS MORE THAN WOULD BE ENOUGH IF
THEY MADE THEIR AVERAGE AGAIN,
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD GET CONTROL
OF THE HOUSE.
THEY HAD A HUGE GAP IN WHAT'S
CALLED A GENERIC BALLOT.
THAT'S THE ONE WHERE YOU ASK
PEOPLE IF THEY WOULD RATHER VOTE
FOR A DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN
UNNAMED IN THE UPCOMING
ELECTION.
NORMALLY DEMOCRATS DO WELL ON
THAT BALLOT.
THEY WERE UP, PLUS 15 OR 16 AT
ONE POINT NOT VERY LONG AGO AND
NOW THAT NUMBER IS DOWN TO
SINGLE DIGITS AND SAMPLES DOWN
BELOW SINGLE DIGITS WHICH
SUGGEST THAT WHATEVER THEY ARE
SELLING PEOPLE ARE NOT BUYING
WITH THE ENTHUSIASM THAT THE
PARTY HAD HOPED FOR.
>> Tucker: WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF
THEY DON'T RETAKE THE HOUSE?
>> WELL, I THINK THERE WILL BE
AN AGONIZING REAPPRAISAL BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT THIS
BLUE WAVE THAT WAS THOUGHT TO BE
INEVITABLE AND MAY YET COME.
IF IT DOESN'T COME, OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S GOING TO BE A SEARCH FOR
SCAPEGOATS AND WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
BUT THIS PARTY I THINK, WHAT WE
ARE SEEING EMERGE NOW IS THAT
FOR ALL THE DIVISIONS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BETWEEN TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AND SO ON AND ALL THE
DIVISIONS WITHIN THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT, THE
DIVISIONS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ARE AT LEAST AS DEEP, IF
NOT DEEPER AND AT THE HEART OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND
REMEMBER YOU SAYING IN A SPEECH
NOT TOO MANY YEARS AGO, WAS NOT
WITH HILLARY CLINTON BUT SHE WON
ANYWAY.
A CANDIDATE OF HER STRIPE I
DON'T THINK WIN THIS TIME.
I DON'T KNOW THAT A WHITE MALE
CANDIDATE COULD WIN.
HERE WE ARE IN THE DEMOCRATS,
THE DEMOCRATS REALLY HAVE SOME
SERIOUS DIVISIONS TO WORRY ABOUT
AND WHETHER WHATEVER THEY COME
UP WITH WILL BE APPEALING TO A
BROAD CROSS SECTION OF VOTERS IS
OBVIOUSLY WHAT REMAINS TO BE
SEEN.
CANDIDATE COULD NOT WIN.
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF THE WHITE
MALE CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION KNOW THAT
YET BUT I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
LEARN.
DO YOU THINK THAT IT MOVES IN
THE DIRECTION OF POPULIST
ECONOMICS, THE ELIZABETH WARREN,
THE BERNIE SANDERS PARTY?
>> I THINK THAT'S THE DRIFT AND
I THINK THAT EXCITES A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
YOU LOOK AT THE ATTITUDES OF
YOUNG VOTERS NOW.
WHO DO NOT SEEM TO HAVE GRASPED
THE BENEFIT OF A MARKET
CAPITALIST ECONOMY AND DON'T
SEEM TO BE PUT OFF AT ALL ABOUT
THE IDEA OF SOCIALISM DESPITE
ITS ABYSMAL HISTORY, WHICH IS
PLAYING OUT EVEN TODAY IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE WORLD,
VENEZUELA BEING THE MOST
CONSPICUOUS EXAMPLE.
BUT I THINK THAT THE PARTY, IT'S
GOTTEN PRETTY FAR LEFT NOW AND A
LOT OF OLD IDEAS THAT ARE BEING
PASSED OFF AS KIND OF NEW IDEAS
ARE IN THE AIR.
IN THE PARTY WILL HAVE TO RECKON
WITH THAT BECAUSE IF THEY COME
UP WITH SOMEBODY WHO WAS A
SOCIALIST FOR PRESIDENT I DON'T
THINK THEY COULD POSSIBLY WIN.
I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY OF THEM WE
WILL SEE BUT THERE WILL BE AWFUL
BATTLES OVER THIS.
>> Tucker: THEIR CORPORATE
DONORS BECAUSE THE PARTY IS
ENTIRELY SUPPORTED BY CORPORATE
AMERICA WILL BE PRETTY SURPRISED
WHEN IT TURNS OUT THERE AND
SENDING MONEY TO HUGO CHAVEZ.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU BATTEN, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: GO AHEAD.
>> DON'T UNDERESTIMATE THE
ABILITY TO RAISE MONEY FOR A
SMALL DONATION AND MAKE A
SERIOUS RUN FOR IT.